whatever you think poverty today looks
like it probably doesn't look much like
this in one of the most affluent
counties in America people are queuing
for handouts of diapers morning do you
have your ID thank you we've had clients
come to us that have said I've rinsed
out a diaper and I've reused it I've
turned a diaper inside out and I've
reused it sometimes I've left my child
in a diaper for far longer than I should
have
there is no government support in
America to help pay for diapers and many
poor families struggle to afford them
America is the richest big country in
the world its unemployment rate couldn't
be much lower so why does it have so
many people living in poverty
[Music]
in America almost 40 million people are
living in poverty
that's nearly 1/8 of the population
living on less than $26,000 a year for a
family of four here's the thing though
poverty and absolute terms has actually
decreased in recent years but the nature
of poverty is changing and that change
is making it much harder to fight
poverty used to be more of an inner-city
phenomenon but as housing costs rocketed
poverty exploded in the suburbs now
there are 3 million more poor people in
suburbs than cities yet suburban
counties spend one-tenth as much to
support poor residents as urban counties
which is why some residents of Lake
County Illinois depend on charity
handouts for diapers our schedule for
the rest of the year so you can come
twice a month just not twice in the same
week
anne-marie mattis is a local mom she set
up the charity nine years ago in her
basement initially she distributed
secondhand children's clothes to poor
families but soon she found there was an
overwhelming need for diapers diapers
cost seventy to eighty dollars a month
per child so that's an expense that many
many families struggle to afford
you're welcome people are faced with you
know not only diaper need bought but
hunger homelessness it's very prevalent
even here in what's considered a a
wealthier community all right you're
outside have a good day
[Music]
Xavier has been using the diaper pantry
for the last few months for her it's a
lifeline our budget goes on rent and
food anything that's not covered by
health insurance let me take this shirt
off you got another one off clothing is
a big thing for five kids yes program
they help out a lot with healthy food
then you can get some vouchers with them
beans cheese milk poverty in America is
becoming more concentrated we know that
the effect of being poor and living in a
poor neighborhood is much worse than
being poor and living in an integrated
neighborhood especially for children in
terms of the kind of school that they go
to or their exposure to crime and it's
children who are affected the most one
child in every six in America is poor I
see other families in there around and
joined us and there at the mall or there
at these events my kids acts enough I
have to keep saying I can't we can't how
did it come to this to understand you
need to go back to the 1960s
[Music]
President Lyndon Johnson went on a
poverty tour of America and he was so
shocked by what he saw he launched an
ambitious plan and this administration
today here and now declares
unconditional war on poverty in America
that war involving an array of programs
designed to create a safety net many of
which still exist in some form today
these included expanding both the cash
benefit for the elderly called Social
Security as well as food stamps which
help poor families buy food and largely
they were successful if we look at the
data without the safety net programs
roughly the same number of Americans
would be as poor today as they were in
the 1960s but if you include the effect
of the safety net programs that number
comes right down
Eldar poverty in the 1950s was a huge
problem but along the way Social
Security hugely reduce the amount of
poverty among the elderly sounds good
but not if you compare America's efforts
with other wealthier countries before
the benefit of safety nets is applied
America's poverty rate is comparatively
low but with it included it's one of the
worst performing only slightly above
Costa Rica in part that's because
America's safety net programs have
tended to benefit the elderly more than
other groups like working age adults and
children those programs are not doing as
much as they might in a country like
Finland for example Finland has a child
poverty rate before taxes and transfers
that are on par with America and after
its safety net kicks in you cut that
down to about 3% I'm in America you
don't do that at all child poverty in
America is remarkably high for an
advanced developed democracy and you
have to ask yourself what is the future
of a society that doesn't invest in it
[Music]
the problem is food stamps for example
can only be spent on specific things
which doesn't always include the most
obvious items unlike Social Security for
the elderly whose recipients are handed
cash to do as they please
it's lunchtime and back at the pantry
it's been a very busy daddy we've given
out five thousand nine hundred and
twenty five diapers so far with an hour
and a half left to go since Anne Marie
started the charity she says they've
given out 1.2 million diapers and every
week more and more families are
registering the safety net programs that
exist in the United States in general do
not cover diapers and that's a common
misconception in the community
the problem is safety net programs are
targeted so that many people don't
qualify they are restrictive there are
behavioral conditions increasingly
attached to them and all of this can
lead to a bureaucratic nightmare of red
tape from which it's almost impossible
to escape in America there is an ongoing
debate about whether giving poor people
cash leads to dependency yet the
evidence from other countries shows that
cash benefits can really help dent
poverty since Canada implemented a child
benefit of a few hundred dollars a month
they have seen their child poverty
numbers declined by about a third it's
reasonable to expect that a program of
similar magnitude in America would also
generate the exact same effect one
candidate for the Democratic
presidential nomination has even made
this a central part of his campaign
[Applause]
Colorado Senator Michael Bennett has
proposed monthly cash transfers of 300
dollars for each American child as part
of wider proposals to help poor people
school kids all over this country
they're living at a time when we've got
the worst income inequality that we've
had in a hundred years you've probably
never heard of it which tells you a lot
about America's political appetite for
reducing poverty poor people are much
less likely to vote so their issues are
rarely vote winners if you're working
two jobs and trying to make sure your
kids are walking safely to school in a
gang-infested neighborhood are you going
to the block party for your member of
Congress and making a campaign donation
so that he or she will listen to you
the pantries closing for the day for the
families who use it poverty does not
need to be inevitable there is a way out
other countries around the world have
done it it's really possible presuming
you're a wealthy country with the
resources and you have a reasonably
strong economy the choice is a political
one I know that it's something better
coming and then we'll look back on in
like we got through it we're strong
we're gonna be stronger because of it
I'm Anna the director of this film if
you'd like to see more and the journey
that brought us to the diaper pantry you
can watch the story behind American
poverty by clicking on the link opposite
the other link will take you to some of
the resources that we use when we were
researching this film including other
exclusive material don't forget to
subscribe so you can see all of our
latest releases and if you hit the bell
button it will notify you whenever we
post a new film thanks for watching
you